[Music]
I'm feeling very pregnant I'm happy
though so she's doing great she's been
preparing for this long before you know
we actually did get pregnant
um so she's very ready it's the last
you're like oh
I know I have heartburn but it's okay
this is the first child for the couple
who tied the knot last September and
second for Keisha who shares
five-year-old daughter Ella with her
ex-husband she's gonna be an awesome big
sister she actually did a really good
job because she kept the secret like
we're like listen Ella you can't
tell anybody so now she's like today
do they kill them Keisha and Brad first
met in 2019 onset of Pride and Prejudice
Atlanta let's just say the 43 year old
fell head over heels for him listen the
carpet there was cables or something she
trips over nothing it was literally just
smooth sailing I definitely almost bit
it Facebook
and he did catch me one of my favorite
things that he's done he had a book made
so it was one of those books where it
like tells like the story of your
relationship and all of the things that
you like love about each other and it's
probably one of my favorite most
thoughtful things that that and when you
got me the goats for Valentine's Day
Biggie and pop Biggie and pop now Keisha
and Brad are putting their love for each
other on full display in a New Orleans
Noel I don't need any distractions
biggest crush on him in college in the
film hitting lifetime tomorrow the two
play competing Architects hired by a New
Orleans praline icon portrayed by Patti
LaBelle and you should have seen us
shooting on the streets of New Orleans
we had people like coming up and bless
their heart they gave it their best try
but nobody is Patty but Patty she's very
right
she literally sat and and people would
sing their little hearts out off key for
us on the street and was so kind and so
sweet and so supportive
[Music]